According
[Music]
to various online sources, Robert
Spencer is controversial among various
other epithets.
Controversial. He's controversial only
in the sense that the clarity,
expertise, and truth that he brings
regarding Islam is contrary to what the
left prefers. contrary to the dominant
narrative that claims that Islam is a
religion of peace and that it is in fact
those of us here in this room who are
more dangerous than those who adhere to
the teachings of Muhammad. And it is for
his dogged truthtelling on this crucial
issue, this civilizational threat, that
we honor him today. Robert was born into
a Greek Orthodox Christian family. His
grandparents were immigrants from the
Ottoman Empire, modern-day Turkey, who
experienced persecution as Christians
under Islamic rule. It is this family
history that shaped his lifelong
interest in the study of Islam and
Christianity, including earning a
master's degree in religious studies
from the University of North Carolina,
Chapel Hill, with a focus on church
history and theological issues. Robert
Spencer is the director of Jihad Watch
and a Schulman fellow at the David
Horowitz Freedom Center and is one of
the world's foremost experts on Islam
and the threats posed to Western
civilization by its incursions into
nations which are founded on
Judeo-Christian principles such as ours.
He is also a senior fellow with the
Center for Security Policy and the
Institute for the American Future and
contributes regularly to their webinars.
Spencer has led countless seminars on
Islam and jihad for various government
agencies and has discussed jihad, Islam,
and terrorism at various workshops in
the US and elsewhere. And of course, he
has written hundreds of articles on the
topic for a wide range of publications.
In addition, Robert Spencer has been a
featured speaker at dozens of
universities and colleges around the
country and has also addressed countless
organizations and conferences. And of
course, he has spoken at several AFA
conferences, including our 2016 event,
Islam and Western Civilization, Can They
Coexist? Several of our World War II
conferences in 2023 and 24. And just
last month, he participated in our Red
Green Access Forum with AFA Board of
Adviserss member Frank Gaffne and AFA
fellow Trevor Lden. Not only has Spencer
been speaking widely about these topics,
but at last count, he has published 31
books on this and related topics. By the
time this video is made, it may well be
32, as the pace with which he writes is
breathtaking. Titles include Islam
Unveiled, The Critical Quran, Various
Infidel Guides to Islam, and Muhammad, a
critical biography, among countless
others.
Not surprisingly, his cander,
unflinching reporting, and superior
expertise on the Quran haven't always
been wellreceived. For his pains he has
been banned from entering the UK, and
the attacks he undergoes here in the
United States are personal, physical,
and financial. He has been deplatformed,
debanked, and in fact poisoned.
We had created this American Freedom
Award in 2017 to honor Phil Haney, the
DHS whistleblower who spoke out against
Islamic terrorism. His passing was a
huge blow to this community. And this
year, we are proud and honored to
present this award to the dogged,
fearless, and unstoppable Robert
Spencer, whose commitment to preserving
our Judeo-Christian civilization
exemplifies the intent and spirit of
this award.
[Music]